[Music]
hey alex what's up
hey how are you dave great man how can
we help
yeah so the reason i called is because
i'm in need of a bit of career advice
okay so i'm 24 years old i don't have
any loan from undergrad
and i plan on starting pharmacy school
later this fall great but most of the
pharmacists that i've spoken to tell me
that the field is no longer worth it
and it's not what it was before it's
becoming really saturated uh the job
outlook is projected to go down
significantly
and also the pay has decreased at least
for like retail pharmacist entry-level
pharmacist
and so i just don't want to go into
something and regret it for the next
you know however many years
if i'm not going to be sure if i i can
pay off all those loans yeah with those
type of projections and uh that's
interesting i have not i have not heard
that i did i didn't you know what i
don't doubt it with the cvs's and the
walgreens entering that space and
largely controlling that space as one of
the major employers um
and it's you know the the and the drug
space in general is moving pretty
rapidly uh
generics and and discounts programs and
uh the the
um cuban just did a thing with drugs and
it was a deal and so yeah that's
interesting i i kind of don't doubt what
you've heard i don't know that
personally but it doesn't it doesn't
sound like it's outlandish to me
so let's let's say all of that's true
what are you going to do
so yeah so that's part of the reason why
i was calling because uh
uh if i've been listening to your show
in like these last couple two weeks i
started listening
and you know all these people getting
into debt they're not being able to pay
it off yeah so that's probably like i
guess there's a fear factor especially
since i haven't had any loans from
undergrad what is your undergrad um
biochemistry
okay
so you're up you're obviously
what's your gpa
3.8 from undergrad good for you okay
well there's a lot of stuff you could do
with that it doesn't have to be pharmacy
it's just that's been your dream a long
time and now talking about changing
horses is scary as crud isn't it
yeah so everything i've done has led to
that and there really hasn't been like a
plan b
yeah
so i don't know if i should stick with
this and hope for the best no
i think you need to play i think you
need to pan back and develop a plan b
and that'll help you decide if you're
going to stick with it
let me give you a decision making tool i
use in all major decisions and i use it
in business i use it personally okay
i always want a lot
of options
the more options i have the better
decision i'm going to make because in
developing the options i learn a lot
about all of the paths in other words
while you're developing option bcde
you're going to learn about pharmacy
things you didn't know today
and and when you feel like you have one
possible path and you're stuck on that
path that seldom results in a good
decision especially when you've got
data and evidence telling you making you
question your decision
and so an example would be years ago i
got ready to lease a building for this
business okay i had one i had my eye on
and i liked it and i thought that was
the right way to go but instead of just
doing that i went and became an expert
on every building in a 10 mile radius
that was for rent what the rent was what
the square footage available was what
the build out cost was going to be and i
spreadsheeted all of it and i put all of
this data down there and then the
gathering of all of that the decision
rose up and it actually was not the
building i thought it was
we ended up going with building b rather
than building a
and it turned out to be one of the best
real estate deals i've ever done in my
life
but i changed i did change course and
the reason i changed course was in the
development of other options because i
refused to make a decision where there's
only one
option
and so that's that when people say for
instance even in a dating relationship
there's only one girl on the planet that
god has for me
you're you're screwed
because that's just not true number one
uh number two you you just you've just
talked your way into marrying crazy or
something's what you just did and that's
a bad idea you know so
i think you may end up back at pharmacy
but george i think he needs a bunch of
options yeah i was telling him he needs
to go into research mode and figure out
what are all of the options based on my
undergrad what are all the schools in
the area who's willing to give me
scholarships what kind of offers am i
getting versus backing yourself into a
corner and going well this is it i gotta
tell you you know what he needs ken
coleman's get clear assessment i like
that hold on i'm gonna give you that
okay it's like a thirty dollar thing on
our website or whatever it is 20 or
something take this quick assessment
it's going to help you get clear and
it'll give you some output it'll give
you some ideas of things to think about
and look at and um i'm even going to go
ahead and give you ken's book from
paycheck to purpose because i think
that's what's going on but for sure take
that get clear assessment and maybe even
call the ken coleman show and talk to
him after you've done this because i
i'm not saying that i that that i don't
i told you earlier in the conversation i
don't have personal knowledge that
pharmacy's dead but what he's saying
does it
doesn't it does smell right yeah and so
i want to look into all the options and
i know that like you said dave
we when we have to shift gears here and
go maybe pharmacy school isn't the thing
that i always thought it was going to be
and now i've got a switch and maybe i go
into research or maybe i go into a
different industry that can be a hard
pill to swallow but i don't want him
calling back five years from now going
dave i regret it i'm 200 000 in debt and
i don't even want to be a pharmacist
well and he's got the he's got the gray
matter to to be a scientist or do
anything he's going to do with what he's
talking about so there's a lot of
different things that directions he can
go it just depends on what you want to
do with your life what do you want when
you come home at night you're tired
is it a good tired
you know
like you know did you feel like you
accomplished something are you working
at something that you're passionate
about and um you know uh you and i
finish uh uh doing one of these live
events and you know we've been on stage
for a couple hours or whatever and we
come off we're tired uh we finished
doing a three hour show we're tired it
takes more energy to do a three-hour
show doesn't work eight-hour day
and so um but that's a good tired
because stuff we love doing yeah and
that's what ken talks about all the
times being plugged into something you
love doing it's a great assessment i
took it myself uh and uh i'm in the
right field dave
i want you to know that well i i it said
i feel wrong because i was i was worried
about that
it said you should be a pharmacist no
i'd be terrible i'll leave that to our
other friend on the line here yeah
yeah you may end up there but uh i'm
gonna do i'm gonna explore some options
because here's the thing
if you do end up back there and you have
looked at all the options you will be
sure it will have pushed the doubt aside
and um
you know i i don't know how many
pharmacists you talk to to get this
information either i might talk to a few
more
try to find someone who's actually happy
they did it and ask them why these other
people are wrong well if you ask
teachers if i should go be a teacher
they'll probably tell you right now the
ones you talk to say ah don't do it but
does that mean teaching is a bad
profession you shouldn't get into it
might be the thing you're called to do
that's true and so that's it's a tough
thing you got to watch out who you
listen to as well yeah that's true
because but but yeah
you need to gather more information
yeah it sounds like you have a limited
thing here it just but it knocked you
off your kilter because you had you had
one thing you were doing and it was like
oh this doesn't happen yeah that's it
i'm with you man hey i hope i hope that
works out for you hang on kelly i'll
pick up we'll give all that to you as
our gift
this is the ramsay show